the sports world at some point won't
necessarily get back to normal but it'll
get back to existing and president trump
mentioned yesterday in his daily
coronavirus
task force briefing that he has convened
a meeting of sports commissioners and
other influential individuals and he
believes that sports will return without
fans and we have been bracing for that
reality for a while now however it's
going to look however it's going to
sound however it's going to feel it's
going to start off without fans but then
the president acknowledged something
that has been bouncing around in the
discussion about this peter for the past
few weeks and that's the possibility of
a phase-in
where
at first instead of the stands opening
up again and being full it's going to be
people with space between them a
checkerboard type of a pattern which is
just going to be bizarre when that
occurs but he believes that's going to
happen and i think people in the sports
world believe that's going to happen
before we get full stadiums back because
look you get some ticket revenue that
way you get some fan interaction and
involvement you just don't have the
full-blown experience and i don't know
when that occurs but i tend to agree
that at some point we will see that
peter we will see these stands partially
filled not because it's a bengals game
sorry bengals but that's kind of how
your games have looked lately but
because that's the limit as to who's
going to be allowed in the stadium
mike i think dr fauci the other day
basically kind of laid out
exactly what this will be
and i've had a couple of conversations
with people around the league who
you know honestly a general manager when
i'm talking to him about the draft
as you understand
they they have a few monitors on because
they're doing a lot of draft stuff and
they might be on a microsoft teams thing
with their team or zoom video conference
or facetime whatever but they also have
the news on they understand what's going
on
and i had two conversations with general
managers this week about
what's happening and i think the first
reaction
to
um five months from now less than five
months from now the kansas city chiefs
are scheduled to open on thursday night
september 10 against somebody houston
maybe atlanta i don't know somebody
and
most likely i'd say
you know
it's getting more and more likely by the
day they'll play in an empty stadium
and
if indeed that happens
how weird and and and strange that it's
going to be if you have to play without
fans
you know in fact steven houston the
buffalo kicker told me last week that
you know he he honestly thinks that
coaches are gonna have to talk to
players
about playing in a stadium without fans
for a variety of reasons you know you
don't want your your signals heard and
all that other stuff
but i do think mike
it is part of the new normal
that we're all going to have to deal
with in the united states and if you are
in the nfl you know
that in some way and i don't want to be
too corny that you're going to be part
of the quote getting back to normal and
sort of the healing of this country
because obviously
once the games start in september if
indeed they do
i think then you have all of the people
who watch the games are going to be
looking forward to it as normal and
remember what's the what's the figure 93
95
of the people who watch nfl games
are watching them on television they're
not watching them in person
so i i really believe that even though
how weird it'll be to not have games
with fans adam i mean it's better to
have the games without the fans than to
not have the games
and one of the realities of these
various plans and possibilities that are
being discussed peter is that every
answer that arises
gives rise to more questions when dr
fauci talks about the feasibility of
playing the games and basically
sequestering the teams in a big hotel
okay fine well who's going to go along
with that who's going to leave his
family behind for four months are they
going to be allowed to have their
families with them in a hotel that all
of a sudden gets even bigger when you
add a spouse and a couple of kids to it
there will be
plenty of issues that need to be
addressed and that's why i continue to
be an advocate of as much planning as
you possibly can do
now because the act of planning the act
of identifying solutions
gives rise to more questions just the
the possibility of a checkerboard
pattern in a stadium to keep fans
sufficiently separate peter how in the
hell do you get the people in and out
how do you get them to the bathroom
right when you're the guy who's dead
center in the row of 20 seats and you've
got people on each side of you
and they're three seats away so while
you're watching the game you have enough
distance how are you going to get past
them if you have to pee right i mean so
it it there are so many que it's just i
feel like it's an avalanche of questions
every time we identify well maybe this
will work question question question
question question it's like i don't know
maybe it won't work but that's what's
frustrating to me because we've got
these ideas spinning around and i just
wonder are people
really taking it all the way to the
bottom of the rabbit hole with all the
questions are going to come up based
upon these various scenarios
well mike i think one of the things that
you're assuming and this was
this was advanced by the
purported baseball model where players
would have to go to arizona for four and
a half months and leave their families
and i just heard an interview yesterday
with mike trout who you know who has a
wife who's gonna deliver a baby this
summer so if the best game and best
player in baseball says i'm not doing it
and obviously time to come up with
another plan
but i don't think it's ever been said
that on labor day weekend
all the players in the nfl have to go
somewhere and be sequestered until
january 1st that's not it
i believe that what fauci was saying was
that every player and every coach every
essential staff member trainer
all that stuff all those people
essentially are going to be tested once
a week
and you know if you don't have fans in
the stands and let's say each team
would need 150 people to be at every
game
well you do a test every week and then
what you do is you take their
temperature at every game and you know
that raises all of the possibilities too
that if patrick mahomes comes in with
101 degree temperature one day instead
of being gutsy and doing the brett favre
oh i'll play with a fever whatever
you're not playing you know so
so i all of these things are going to
come up but i don't believe that
the nfl or i can tell you the nfl pa is
gonna is going to sign off on people
leaving their families for four months
to play football i think or not that
they will be tested every week
but i don't think that they're gonna
have to be monks every week
i'll just say this peter if you don't
sequester the players from the normal
pathways to being exposed to the virus
especially if schools are open and the
kids may be bringing it home any given
day you better test them a lot more
frequently than once a week because all
it takes is one guy to bring it into the
locker room and it's going to spread
like wildfire so i i don't know what the
quality of the testing is going to be
when we get to september
but
ideally you'd want to screen a guy for
it and know whether or not he has it
before he walks into the building every
day because all it takes is that one guy
and then you have and again this is why
i'm saying every every answer we come up
with
triggers more questions what if one guy
has it how long has he taken out of
circulation who else is taken out of
circulation and you have to be
willing to apply the same rules to the
backup center that you apply to the
franchise quarterback if tom brady tests
positive even if he's completely
asymptomatic so
every answer spawns more questions and
hope hopefully people far smarter than
us are addressing those questions and
coming up with the answers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports